i feel like everybody at some point in
their life has met somebody
who was truly inspiring you know they
seem to have their life figured out they
are determined
they can carve out their own destiny
they create their own
luck and on the flip side a lot of us
have met people who seem to just
bury themselves in a hole and are unable
to get out of it you know they're unable
to recognize the opportunities in front
of them
they harbor a lot of negativity towards
life and they seem
perpetually stuck helpless against
seemingly endless
negative external forces and i feel like
a lot of people talk about
these two types of people and try to
distill one single
belief or concept that separates the two
of them
and if you just adopt this belief then
you'll be like the successful person and
not like the unsuccessful person but i
feel like it's a little foolish to do so
because
everybody's life is so wildly different
you know people had different
upbringings people have
such different instilled beliefs about
the world or
religion or whatever it's hard to just
say that
one single belief will change someone's
life for the better
for eternity and they'll never
experience hardship again but i have
noticed
one trait that successful people seem to
share more often than unsuccessful
people
and i can't help but think that there is
a strong correlation
between having that belief and having
success
in life and that is that successful
people
tend to have an internal locus of
control
and less successful people tend to have
an external one
so what is locus of control locus of
control is
the degree to which people believe that
they
as opposed to external forces have
control over the outcome of events in
their lives
so you watching this right now either
have an external locus of control or an
internal locus of control and i think
the severity of either of these extremes
was formed through your childhood and
your development
and your transition into adulthood
because children
very young children especially have an
external locus of control
external forces have control over the
outcomes of events in their lives
when you're a kid you're pretty much
absolutely helpless
especially when you're a very young kid
you know you can't really feed yourself
or clothe yourself
you're so dependent on a parental figure
to provide you with
all of your needs that you basically
have no choice but to develop a very
external locus of control
the situations of your life are entirely
out of your control and you're entirely
dependent on some sort of third party
to provide you with what you need to
survive and there's nothing wrong with
that like kids don't really have a
choice
in the matter that is their world that's
a factual and
realistic belief to have as a kid but
hopefully you had a competent
parental figure or leader as you were
growing up
that kind of taught you the ropes how to
cook how to clean
how to make money how to fend for
yourself in the world
i've always thought that if a parent
does their job right they basically
phase themselves out hopefully by the
time you're an adult
you still want your parents around but
you don't need them around you know if
they were to die
you'd be okay like you could fend for
yourself you can figure stuff out but
unfortunately for a lot of us
we bring a lot of the helplessness of
childhood
into adulthood we never shake the idea
that we need to be provided for somehow
we remain dependent on some sort of
external system
to provide us with the necessary
materials to survive and thrive
and a lot of the time this is really
hard to spot from an occupational
standpoint
sometimes this can look like you know
being unsatisfied with your job
and you're working so hard but getting
paid so little
so you externalize this struggle onto
your boss
or your provider and you blame him for
your life's problems you know my life
sucks because my boss doesn't see how
much i'm worth and he's not paying me
enough money or you might look at the
government and say
you know the government's not giving me
the proper tax breaks that i need in my
societal class and it's making it really
hard for me and the tricky thing is
that a lot of the time these are valid
complaints there's
a certain amount of logic to them but
the default
shouldn't be to place all the blame and
place
all of the responsibility for changing
the outcome of your life
onto these external forces otherwise we
will just be
imprisoned by them for our entire lives
our default should be to look at the
cards that we are given
and take full responsibility for how we
play those cards
i feel like having this internal locus
of control it's extremely important
in today's day and age because obviously
in 2020 we were just hit with a global
pandemic
and so much of that felt so far
out of our control that it was very
tempting
i know for me personally it was to
develop a feeling of
helplessness almost that childlike
helplessness started to
blossom again and i felt like i had to
put my entire life on hold
put all my habits on hold until this
whole pandemic blew over
sometime halfway through i realized that
i can work
within this system there are things that
i can do
to improve my life despite the crappy
situation
and it is my sole responsibility to
figure out how to thrive
within the environment that i've been
placed it's nobody's responsibility to
come be your knight in shining armor
and fight the dragons in your life it's
only your responsibility
and i don't want this to come across
like i'm scolding you like
the father you never had no i'm just
kidding but hopefully to empower you
once you start adopting more of an
internal locus of control
it'll start to feel a lot less like life
is happening to you
but it'll start to feel a lot more like
life is happening due to you
and that's a very empowering belief to
have in fact i would say it's a
prerequisite to making any sort of
substantial change in your life
your positive actions to work your way
out of a bad situation
do have an impact your efforts are not
in vain
because not only do you have the power
to change your life
you're the only one who does
videos like these are made possible
thanks to amazing sponsors like
skillshare i actually recently just
bought a
kind of expensive piano and i did this
so that i would have no excuse
not to get better at jazz improv
probably not the best use of my money
but i couldn't resist
unfortunately due to the pandemic it's
really hard to find in person classes
right now
thankfully skillshare is kind of the
next best thing and charles cornell
a youtuber that you guys might know has
an amazing improvisational piano class
on skillshare so i'm diving headfirst
into that and i'm learning a lot of new
things
and i get to use that piano and it's
just a win-win for those of you who
don't know
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes
covering dozens of topics
everything from music lessons to
photography and videography
to the culinary arts and productivity no
matter what you're into or what you want
to learn
skillshare probably has a class for it
and chances are it's also
very practical because all the classes
on skillshare
are designed for real life it's super
easy to take whatever you're learning on
skillshare
and apply it directly to your real-life
pursuits not only is it such a useful
tool but it's also
extremely affordable if you get the
annual membership it comes in at less
than ten dollars a month
so it's kind of a no brainer and the
first 1000 of you who click the link in
the description below
will get a free trial of a skillshare
premium membership so in like
less than two minutes you can be diving
into your first class on skillshare
using the amazing offer down below
learn something new explore your
creativity and as usual
have a great time oh hey if you liked
this video
make sure that you hit like because when
you hit like
the algorithm blesses me and it shoves
my
very bald head because i just bicked it
today
shoves my bald head into other people's
home pages helping them out
it also helps me out so it's kind of a
win-win for everybody
if you're lurking here and this is the
thousandth time that you've seen my face
and this is the thousandth time that
you've seen my face
consider subscribing uh and hitting the
bell icon
so that the next time i upload a new
video you get notified
actually you know what no
we don't need more notifications in our
life right you know
just like hit the bell icon if you
really want to get notified but
hell get off the notification train free
yourself from this
algorithmic living and uh don't hit the
bell icon if you've hit the bell icon
unhit it you know that's a bold move but
i don't know i feel like the algorithm
probably will still serve you the video
uh anyways i'm not going crazy
you're going crazy uh catch you in the
next video it's gonna be really really
quick within the next few days actually
and it's going to feature a
special guest that you guys already know
you all know him and he'll be in the
video so
see ya